hey guys my name is zinyu i'm new here
and today i have something very special
for you rainbow six siege fans out there
i have the year six collectors case
filled with a bunch of goodies from the
game itself and i've not seen anything
inside and i'm super excited to open it
up so let's do this
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
headshots with the logitech g pro x
super light mouse the lightweight
wireless mouse combines excellent
performance with a classy no-frills look
designed with pros and engineer to win
it offers crisp and responsive clicks
the smooth operator even allows you to
swap out the magnetic dongle storage
compartment for greater gliding ease
check out all of its other features over
at logitechg.com
all right so for the main box there's
honestly nothing much going on down here
it's just really plain but it's really
nice and minimal so on the front we have
cavera and flores and the back
we have
ghost guliana and jackal who everyone
hates all right moving on let's just
open this baby up
the first thing i see as i open this box
oh lord this thing is finicky all right
hold on just like
first thing you see
is
lol chanka in the sparkle skin and he
looks really cute you know we all love
him
he has his signature lmg on as well
oh damn right i should do that
oh yeah so there is a code down here
which i obviously cannot show
that unlocks the free chunka sparkle
charm for your weapons so that comes
together with the chibi
and
the main man himself
it's really cute i love it
look at this boy
look at him
unicorn horn rainbow hair at the bottom
it says the siege logo with rainbows as
well
put in this boy
here whole bunch of stuff at the back
oh okay so with every there are only 7
000 boxes of these so with every box of
the collector's case a letter of
authenticity so ours is numbered number
780 and it comes with signatures with
the entire team that is working on seat
as well right and moving on from the
letter of authenticity we actually have
um two pamphlets on here which has codes
behind them to redeem
digital content so you have skins for
characters like such as iyada and zero
and also skins weapons right
what's here oh we also have um aleppo
and it comes with oh okay you have three
kinds of art from community artists so
you can see like uh like valkyrie to
kaibi iq and
maestro at the back here you know
that's cute yeah no this is really cute
i love it you know you got
oh my god i think it's oh i kind of oh
my god who there it is i i don't know
what that is i can't remember who's that
but obviously you have ash you have oh
my god this one everyone hates us she's
clash ah clash that's the name clash
caveira again the chunk of sparkler
right here and obviously ella where
everyone loves and the last one would be
outside the garage and um on on voila on
shelley with warden smoke frost and zero
again
so with nothing else inside the box
we have the piece that resistance of the
collector's case it is
sledge's hammer i know i thought it'd be
bigger but it's not you know i actually
wanted to do like the whole frank castle
kefap thing
but you can't do that with this but oh
oh it's it's weighted so let's open it
up
we have the gacha effects from uh six
each and everything i'm not sure what's
inside open it okay okay you want me to
open it yeah all right
[Music]
who are you gonna get
oh it's gold
iq guys and i'm an iq main so this
honestly works out for me yeah so you
get an iq keychain together with the
collector's edition for the collector's
case sorry
and on top of that you also have a
velcro patch and obviously you know this
this task force one for one fetch is
from you know it's it's a call of duty
thing
and just to keep in line with this video
i'm gonna strip it off real quick hold
on one second
right and then just what bam it's right
there and on top of that
sluggish hammer looks pretty sick it
feels like a hammer and installation is
fairly easy it's just
just screw these two parts in
really quick
it feels rubbery or anything
and it's
really sturdy as well
like you can actually do damage with
this thing uh at the end obviously there
is the crowbar tool you know center for
all you breaching pullers out there in
the last part
oh yeah okay so and this just comes this
is just the the display piece first
ledger's hammer and i think
you know like like that's about it
you're good it's honestly nothing much
going for it shiny it's shiny yeah but
oh god damn okay yeah you all need to
check the packaging so this thing goes
oh this thing doesn't go down here
and we have the display set up already
it's all looking nice and pretty down
here with the gold r6 logo so what will
make this bet though
is a hammer
so just put this down just gently nicely
[Music]
and we'll bam pops your uncle it's an
amazing piece any siege player would
appreciate this
so we have everything laid out from the
year 6 collection case but we have just
one more thing for you guys
we got hibana everyone
so this is straight from the ubisoft
store the ubi collection let's take a
closer look right
right so she's fresh from the case she's
holding a little fidget spinner
explosives down here that you shoot up
with a gadget on here i forgot the name
because i'm not i'm not hibana mean i
don't i don't usually play here that
often but this version of it it's pretty
slick and everything you know you're
going to cur the caribbean details the
details are amazing
um you also have a little like um hong
kong police band on here as well
it's a really sick figurine oh i call it
i said hong kong but she's from japan
with a little
japanese police badge down here the
police sash on here it's a great model
of uh the og skin for hibana
right and the last thing from
the hibana package which i can't show
you but you guys can definitely search
it up online it is a skin for type 89
it's
basically just a picture
of
it's basically a skin with a fidget
spinners on it as well if you want to
get these for yourselves pre-orders are
available right now prices and details
are in the description box below don't
forget to like and subscribe guys this
is your boy xeno signing off i'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]